this episode is sponsored by google play
get marvel future revolution and
discover more on google play
[Music]
before shanghi brings hard-hitting kung
fu action to the mcu revisit marvel's
first attempt at a martial art show but
that's only because it was poorly shot
horribly written terribly acted and an
embarrassment to everyone involved
iron fist
meet danny rand ah yep that's him the
white guy doing tai chi in his
girlfriend's apartment he's a copy of a
copy of bruce wayne come on
i'm a billionaire complete with a tragic
backstory where his mom gets absolutely
heated out an airplane
his own corporation and combat training
that makes him almost as deadly as a gun
that only works at point-blank range
your fist lights up it's really exciting
all wrapped up with a world view of a
trust fund kid who spent a semester in
tibet it's a buddhist tradition
it's meant to remind you of our bond
oh man i hate this guy
when danny returns to new york after a
15-year absence he'll be shocked by
things like cars cafes and intersections
like a complete and while he
learns about brand new inventions like a
computer monitor
this is new we'll learn about how he
left the monks who raised him to die
he's gone it's all my fault ruined the
lives of his closest friends how can you
come into my life level it to the ground
and then walk away believing he's a hero
bankrupts his family's corporation we
need to sell the drug at cost
shatters his girlfriend's sense of self
and gets her to close her business is
this a karate school it was
and tries to stop a gang war that he
helped create the undergone but when
they left
they left a power vacuum but you better
believe that this one punch man will try
his best and it's worse now than it was
before you're trying your best okay oh
it's a good thing you're pretty
get ready for one of the most glacially
paced shows even by marvel netflix
standards squeezing 23 hours out of the
premise guy tries to punch crime but
can't that keeps pumping the brakes in
the story to pat at the run time with
excruciating amounts of legwork we need
to know more before we can uh decide how
we should proceed so we just wait
yeah being vague for no reason other
than to keep the story from progressing
where have you been the last 15
years i've
i've been away
away yes i know but where
meetings this will hit market in asia
africa south and central america inside
you'll find all the reports from federal
state and local agencies the rest of our
partners will be using the company's
shipping network an annual payout over
10 years at 45 20
our stock which is already falling
we'll plummet and repetition i've spent
the last 15 years learning to control my
emotions the final step is controlling
your emotions if i linger in that i'm
giving myself over to those emotions
show me you can control your emotions
although you can control your emotions
when you face it how am i supposed to
control my emotions when you're getting
in my face like this you said you had
this under control
stare in awe as actor finn jones clearly
blew off his fight training forcing the
team to use every trick in the book to
hide how he has the on-camera fighting
ability of steven seagal
no i mean present-day st vince gaul
[Music]
setting half of the fights in the dark
keeping his face obscured
shooting him from weird angles
[Music]
giving him the skip by cheat code
or just giving up and give the biggest
fights to his co-stars
[Applause]
because when they can avoid showing the
lead actor fight on camera it's it's
best not to look it's sad
is he showing off those nunchucks or
learning to use them i can't even tell
fighting by danny's side is colleen wing
a martial arts instructor he randomly
meets in the park who just so happened
to be trained by the same secret society
he's pledged to destroy hey only in new
york right she's the one leading the
series who bothers to make the fighting
look good and she's brave enough to see
if denny is better in the sheets than he
is in the streets nice but this show is
more than just a reunion of game of
thrones most disposable supporting
characters it also asks what if
succession was terrible enter the
meachams there's ward and joy danny's
childhood friends turned adversaries
turned friends again turned subplots
that go absolutely nowhere and harold a
man making evil plans from his sweet
bachelor pad with a live-in
assistant kyle
they'll team up with davos danny's
friend from karate camp who doesn't mix
well with his home friends mary walker
an assassin who can only be defeated by
three of the most common things in any
east coast city sound of running water
bright strobing lights prolonged
exposure to cold and the hand a ruthless
global ninja mystic mafia that they
somehow made boring 1948
a group of chinese soldiers got lost in
the mountains during a mission being
recorded for propaganda purposes they
were headed into a remote area but
spend the first season watching danny
wind his way back into being a
billionaire and the second season
watching
none of you watch the second season
so revisit the show that plays as a
rambling companion piece to the other
mcnu from a creator who left after one
season to make the only marvel thing of
the 2000s that's even worse but at the
end of the day it's just another bloated
boring netflix show with zero connection
to any of the characters people already
cared about well at least everybody gets
to have some sex marvel won't do that
anymore you can even pretend they're
talking about fisting each other all the
time there are not many people in this
world who can handle that thing
his fist does how many times a night you
light that fist up does talk happen with
your fists
that's
more of a sharing of ideas
we find a way to get the fist out of
davos
starring
the curls with a dragon tattoo can she
and finn jones switch paychecks crappy
crappy joy joy all's fair amir in love
and war i don't like ran he's coarse and
rough and irritating rosario brawlson do
not pass gao do not collect your heroine
money namaste woke kung fu milhouse the
obligatory hallway fights
karen's i'm calling the police we have
to call the police you need to go to the
police
please we call the police oh let's call
the police you want to call the cops
call the police i said i was going to
call the police so many lines of
dialogue they just i mean wow you really
didn't make it easy on these actors did
you i mean this city's intoxicating
every corner of it hopes and dreams are
seeded into the sidewalk here
sometimes they blossom
and take off your
huge
stunt double in little china
you know i think this season two episode
is the only time in ncu history that a
hero has tried to stop a villain's evil
plan with a dinner party avengers should
have tried this with thanos
this episode is sponsored by google play
get marvel future revolution and
discover more on google play
be careful what you wish for parker
candyman
five times
alexa set the moon